from a robot hand to a rubber one used
by PhD students at the University of
Freiburg to creatively fool the brain
whether you're into psychology or
whether you're into stroking strangers
hands Oh indeed into cutlery I think
there really is something in here for
everybody so why is he behaving like
he's just been for so initially when
he's just sitting there with the fake
hand visible in front of him he knows
it's a fake hand if eyes are telling him
it's a fake hand but when the stroking
starts to happen and that information
starts coming back from his real hand
those two messages start to conflict
with each other and bit by bit
Arpi starting to believe that this hand
that he's seeing is in fact also the
hand that he's feeling even though it's
not so his body readjusts is
understanding of where his body parts
are and begins to believe that this fake
hand here is actually part of his body
so then when his friend comes in with a
fork his brain says get out of the way
that's my hand
but before you try this at home a word
of warning if you're gonna try this at
home make sure you remember which one is
the rubber hand before you stab it with
a fork that's the part you don't want to
get wrong